nfd price
crash debate on whether stimulus led
fat is over this is a bloomberg story
how it started in february 20 000 buyers
spent more than 45 million dollars
on basketball clips in a single day let
me say that one more time 20
000 buyers spent 45 million dollars on
basketball clips in a single day today
the average price of nft is essentially
trading
tradable digital certificates that use
blockchain technologies to prove
ownership and pro
provenance on online assets have tumbled
almost
70 percent from a peak in february to
about fourteen hundred dollars chris
wilmer university of pittsburgh academic
who
co-edited to blockchain research journal
said nfts aren't in a bubble any more
than cryptocurrencies
is a bubble there will be manias and
irrational exuberance but
cryptocurrencies cleared here to stay
with us for the long term and nfts are
probably two nfts are far
from risk-free whether due to further
further price drops
so-called wash training trading where
deals that look uh
genuine are actually done by small group
to create an illusion of high demand
or plain fraud i'm going to read that
last part one more time folks if you're
listening
let me read that last part again and i
want to give your thoughts on this
nfts are far from risk-free whether due
to further price
drops so-called wash trading wash
trading it's a wash you buy from a
friend at a high price
and you kind of make it work but the
price of the nft goes higher
where deals that look genuine are
actually done by small groups to create
an illusion of high demand
or plain fraud that is happening that's
not everybody that's happening with a
small percentage that's given a bad rep
tom
thoughts on nfts well you know what
easter was yesterday and there is
no new sin in the world that's what we
found out the sinfulness and the greed
of man
is consistent and what you see here on
nfts there's a little phrase called pump
and dump
and that written down right here yep
that's exactly right this has been going
on
since the pink sheets hey i've got the
pink sheets by the way which were
ultra low jordan belford yeah the ultra
low special correct ultra low price
stocks are out there
a bunch of guys get together create some
trades there's a little pop looks like
momentum they
they get on the phone uh start calling
people
fake research reports pump and dump pop
pop
boom oh my gosh you're right i just
looked at that thing you're right it was
at two yesterday and that's two and a
half now it's three three and a quarter
four
oh my goodness at four dollars a share i
could get in there with wow a hundred
dollars i get 25
wow i could put the thousand dollars i
could get this pumping up tomorrow
morning it's back up 1.75
and so it's nothing new it's nothing
going on it's going to continue going on
an unregulated product today and for
people that
you know millennials or someone maybe
younger younger entrepreneurs listening
pumping up with something that was
happening in the 70s and 80s and kind of
that kind of went away but in wolf of
wall street you saw the the
the i'm going to give a compliment
different side of what you're saying
right so what i'm saying is
this is nothing new and so people say
wow where did this come from
this crime is not a new idea i'm going
to give you a completely different side
yeah did you want to say something on
that
i kind of know where you're going but
i'm gonna i think i think the fact that
it is
non-fungible this key word for you know
where i'm going
yeah so i don't i mean i'm setting you
up for dude why don't you just tell us
your gift of reading people's minds oh
yeah i mean i understand
well i'll tell you why tell me because
i'm going to bring this back to you now
baby say it
because i loved your intro from that
video you did yesterday and you said
look you know
you you everyone you've seen pat you're
a researcher as well i'm becoming more
of a researcher
you know the osmosis with the biz doc
but you said i don't
i don't i say i don't know what uh what
crypto is i'm not
i don't understand what bit uh
blockchain is what's an nft what's
fungible i don't know what fungible
means
i don't and then you said listen a lot
of people don't know it's okay
do your research and i had to do dude
and i got
a year ago if you asked me what an nft
was i was like what did you just spell
nfl wrong
i have no clue what it was a year ago
most people don't even know what
fungible was two weeks ago okay there we
go today
but you are a good mind reader you have
espn
an nfl reference espn we're going sports
here not too much sportster valuetainers
um but that's where i'm thinking that
you know your story that you always tell
about the picasso
but the freaking picasso yeah but the
guy he goes to the death bed and sees
picasso in his last painting
the beauty of these non-fungibles is you
can't
duplicate them you can't sort of bring
the pump and dump corruption mentality
to this so i'm setting you up because
i'm sure you have a lot more to
elaborate on
i'm going a completely different
direction okay so i'm going a completely
different direction so the story starts
off with us talking about stimulus
checks right yes sir
what these kids did and then tom talked
about them being responsible and you
talk about the
one girl you met in miami that spend
what forty two hundred dollars
i'm assuming that's 1400 times three
which is forty five dollars
great she blew it so that's what she did
right here's here's where i go
go to the 18 year old tom go to the 18
year old when i was partying in spring
break
when he was a miami non-stop go to the
18 year old pbd right
my chain and my clock yeah i can see
that chain 100 you're in flavor
but if you go back to the 20 20 year old
18 euro pbd i'm in the army i'm getting
out of the army
i have no clue what to do okay let me
tell you what i did with my money let me
tell you what i did with my money
uh i did anything i could to 10x my
money okay
i bought penny stocks i bought a penny
stock one time for five cents
this penny stock within a week went to
75 cents
i was on top of the world for one hour
and then it went back to three cents and
i thought you know i should have got out
i didn't get out though i didn't get up
because with penny stocks you can't sell
as fast as you can with you know
different kind of stocks a different
kind of thing
so then i said you know what screw this
i took my money and i just went and
bought a bunch of nike stock i started
fooling around online and then i went
and bought
a bunch of different things i started
risking my money in these different
things
you know how much i ended up losing i
lost forty nine thousand dollars i was
on forty nine thousand dollars of debt
in my early twenties
debt in my early twenties why taking a
crap
load of risk nonsense risk that had no
clue
what i was doing with my money an
informed risk uninformed risk then
finally
non-research risks
21 22 i get my series seven okay i go to
morgan stanley you get my 63 all those
licenses that comes to me
then i started learning about the
ability to research then i start
focusing on one industry things change
here's my point
if you're young and you're listening to
this
you're 18 19 20 21 and you're screwing
off with your money you're throwing into
nfts or whatever you're doing
there's a part of me that says that 18
year old tom may have done that a little
bit
there's a part of me that says the 18
year old adam may have been like you
know what i don't know there's a part of
me that says
because you know as you get older all
you want to do is you want to talk about
how responsible we were and we forget
about how irresponsible
we were and there's an element of taking
that risk that the younger generation is
doing
if you're going to spend 4 200 at a
nightclub versus putting it in nft's
guess what i'm banking for
yeah going to the nfts you know going to
the nfts and see what that can turn into
but if there is any advice you can take
from three men sitting at this table in
their 40s i'm going to leave it at that
three gentlemen sitting at this table in
their 40s 40s means you're about 40. so
we're all in our 40s
is do some research on any
of these topics so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you